hi I'm Garrick Ruhlman a professional
educator our studio and the author of
two books on our I've put together these
videos to teach you some of the main
ideas of doing data wrangling with our
and the tidy verse if you're not
familiar with the tidy verse it's a
collection of our packages that are
designed to help you do data science in
this series of short videos we will walk
through some of the most useful tools
for wrangling your data with the are
also keep in mind that you can skip
around these videos to the tool that you
want by clicking the jump to links in
the video description but let's turn our
attention now to the deep hire package
which has a different design data sets
contain more information than they
display and deep liar is designed to
help you sort of access that information
so you'll need to run my Brady plan
before you use the functions in this
package you'll also need to install the
package of course if you want to use it
the main functions that we'll use for
manipulating data are listed here there
help pages but we'll just go through
them one at a time also I don't think
I'll have a chance to open up this data
set by with planning maybe using this or
some examples the NYC flights 13 package
just contains datasets related to
flights that went in and out of New York
City it has a great place to look at
things as real data and it's somewhat
interesting especially if you fly into
New York City so when it comes to the
accessing information in your data frame
it can help to just extract information
that's already there to avoid the sort
of overwhelming amounts of distraction
that the other variables provides so you
can extract variables you can extract
observations you could drive new
variables and you can change the unit of
analysis that the datasets place and
I'll talk about that let me get there
deep liar provides four functions each
dedicated to doing one of these things
and let's take a look at them starting
with select so select is very simple
it's a way for you to just pull out
variables or columns from a data frame
so if I only wanted the storm column in
the pressure column from the storms data
frame then I could select from storms
the storm
pressure call and you could list as many
call names or as few call names as you
want there and it will bring back
everything you list so that's easy
enough to do in our and why you might
ask why would you select to do it well
one thing that's like does is it
provides more ways to specify which
columns you want so you'll know that if
you use brackets and integer sub setting
you could put a negative sign in front
of an integer and that stands in our
forgive me everything except this
integer
well it's select you could put a
negative sign in front of a name and
you'll get back everything except that
name so here we did everything except
the storm call you could also use the
colon notation to get a range of
variables so this would say give me back
the wind variable the date variable and
any variable that appears in between
them so would I do the same as a
previous command and then there's other
functions that you can use inside of
select come with the applier then make
it even easier so here's a list of those
functions and you can see they allow you
to pull out columns whose names have
like a certain string in them or a
certain rate of expression or begin with
a certain word or end with a certain
word or you know is it a group of names
and so on so if you have a very large
data set selecting variables out of it
might be an important task these
functions might make it very easy for
you to sort of search through the
variable name space in an automated
fashion filter is analogous to select
except instead of selecting columns it
brings back rows or if your days tidy
these would be observations and the way
filter works is you give it a logical
test so here I'm giving it the test
where wind is greater than or equal to
50 what filter will do is I'll apply
that test to each row in your data frame
and give you back just the roads that
pass the test
you can combine tests by putting a comma
in between tests and what filter will do
is they'll combine them as if there is
an end statement between them so these
are only the rows where the wind is
greater than 50 and the name the storm
name is in Alberto Alex and Alison if
you want to do in a work condition we'll
just use the boolean operator for or an
R to combine two tests into a single
test that's the pipe operator so filter
works best if you know how to use
logical tests in R and here's a quick
list of the logical tests that exist in
our the table on the right are boolean
operators these combine to a more
logical test into a single logical test
so you'll get single true or false and
the ones on the left actually do logical
operations you'll notice at the bottom
that is n/a and exclamation mark is that
n/a are in there which means filters a
great way to window out rows that have
na values if you combine it with is dot
na or exclamation mark is de na all
right
the mutate function takes your data
frame and it returns a copy of the data
frame with new variables added to it
normally these will be variables that
you derive from the variable set exist
in your data so before we had sort of
the bogus example of calculating a ratio
variable from the wind and pressure
variable storms the information that
ratio variable was in the data to begin
with it just wasn't on display but you
you could logically drive it from the
data that's there and this is how you do
it with mutate I you run mutate on the
data frame we want to add to or change
and then you give it the name of the new
column you want to make and you set that
equal to some expression that will make
the values of the new column you can
make more than one column at the same
time and you can even use a column to
make a new column in the same command
make sure that the first column appears
before the columns that rely on it so
here in reverse relies on ratio and
since ratio appears first inverse we'll
be able to find ratio and use it to
calculate numbers this can
mutate doesn't actually affect your
original data frame it returns a data
frame that has the new variables added
to it so if you want to save that that
data frame use those variables later
you'll need to assign it to an object
there are a lot of functions that are
useful to use with mutate to making
variables this is a short list of them
this list by the way also appears on
that cheat sheet goals you can download
from our studio website and each of
these functions has something in common
they all take a vector and return vector
the same length so if you want to add a
column on to your data frame that
columns gonna have to have values for
each row in the data frame when you use
these functions you'll get a set of
values that will fit right off with your
data frame you can call these window
functions because they sort of pass the
whole vector through a window and the
vector changes but each elements it's
still represented at the end okay so the
last of those four functions we we
listed with summarize in summarize takes
a data frame and a calculate summary
statistics from it you get back a new
data frame and usually that new data
frame is much much smaller for example
here I'm summarizing the pollution data
frame by calculating the median value of
the mouse I only need one value to show
the median so my new data frame only has
one row I'm also calculating the
variance so my floor works similar to
mutate you give it the name of the new
columns you want in your new summary
data frame and then you set those names
equal to the the R code that will build
those values like mutate
functions that seem to work best with
summarize and things like the standard
statistical estimators men means
variance standard deviation median and
all these functions are similar to each
other in a corner way
unlike the window functions use with
mutate these functions actually all take
a vector or a group of numbers and
return a single number so you could
think them as summarizing functions or
summary functions and when you use some
summarize you'll want to use these
summarizing functions to build your
summary statistics there's one more
function in deep hire that doesn't
really add to your data or subtract from
it but you can consider like a fifth
Horseman of the player and that's a
range what a range will do is they'll
rearrange the order of the rows in your
data frame based on the value of one of
the columns so here I rearrange the rows
and storms based on the value of wind
and if we color-coded this data set you
could see that it's easier to see that
whereas before the rows were not ordered
by wind value now they go from the row
with the smallest wind value to the row
with the highest wind value if you want
to reorder them in a different way in
descending order
use this helper function D ESC it stands
for descend just wrap that around the
variable whose values you want to be
ordered from highest to lowest so now
the highest wind is at the top of the
dataframe
if you give a range one variable it will
range based on that variable and Tyus
will just occur in the order they appear
in the data frame but if you give it a
second or third variable arrange will
use that variables
tie a tie breaker variable within rows
that have the same values of preceding
variables so you can see here that by
adding D as a tie breaker the order of
Alex and Arthur changes even though Alex
and Arthur both had a wind speed of 45
the date of Arthur comes before day Alex
okay so I mentioned that pipe operator
earlier and this is where it really
starts to come into play you could
select data from your data frame you
know in the regular are away well you
can do the same thing with the pipe
operator so now I'm just piping storms
into the Select command same with filter
same with all these functions each of
these functions takes the name of the
data frame that's our first argument
which makes this really convenient and
then if you use the piping syntax it's
very simple to pipe the results after
one expression into a second expression
so if you want to first filter the rows
to extract all the rows for windscreen
50 and then take those results and
select two variables from it you could
just add a second pipe operator in the
selectmen at the end of your code if you
then want to mutate that data frame or
summarize it well then you could add a
third pipe operator in the next line and
so on and so on so it becomes very easy
to build up this sort of record of what
you're doing to transform your data and
it's very easy to add to that record and
then if you read through what we're
doing here I think this way of reading
code is actually very transparent take
storms then filter it to just a rows
where wind speeds green 50 then select
from it storm and pressure just read the
piping the operator is thin and I think
it makes your code very legible okay so
you should be able to guess with
something like this would you if you
start with storms then you mutate it to
create a ratio variable and then you
select from adjust the storm variable on
the ratio variable what would your
output look like something like this if
you don't
typing percent greater than percent
there's a keyboard shortcut for that
operator it's command shift M on Mac and
ctrl shift m' on Windows but uh let's
turn our attention to unit of analysis I
apologize I realize I'm not answering
people's questions and actually when I'm
playing the slideshow I can't see your
questions but I will get to some of
yours at the end so this is where I
think those five functions I mentioned
are they're really become interesting
this is our pollution data set you know
it describes pollution particle amounts
in three different cities and we could
calculate the mean amount to some of the
amounts and the number of rows in the
state of frame and put them in the
summary data set if we look at that it's
summary de sit on the side there well
alright let's look at pollution first
you'll notice as the tidied a said it
has variables
it has observations and if you look at
the summary de set it also has variables
in this case three variables and it does
have an observation on just one
observation but each of these things
that mean the summoning in each of those
values describes the same thing and that
should raise the question what is it
that those values describe and if you
think of a mean of 42 or a sum of 252 or
even an N of six rows becomes pretty
clear that what they're describing is
this entire data set it's almost like
we've made measurements on de set it's
made an observation on the data set an
all-day set is is a grouping of
observations or grouping a rows so if we
make observations on the entire data set
well then we could also make
observations on subsets of a data set we
can make an observation on six rows why
not make an observation on two rows or
three observations on two rows and if we
did that then we could have mean sums
and ends that are keyed into in this
case different cities you know the mean
amount for New York the mean amount for
London meet mal for Beijing you can do
this sort of thing the screw PI's
operation by combining the group by
function which comes from deep wire with
the summarize function that comes from
deep liar here's how it works
if you run group I on the data frame and
then you give group by the name of a
column or
variable it will add some metadata to
the data frame that tells our or tells D
prior what the different groups of rows
are in the data frame in this case I
will group the data into three groups
one group for each unique value of the
city variable now at this point it
doesn't do anything if you just ran this
that metadata will stick around with
your data frame and the applier might
use it if you run a deep layer command
on that group data frame but in essence
you know it just shows up it's basically
here when you look at the table format
it'll tell you if the data is grouped
unless group by in this case is grouped
by the city variable the magic happens
when you combine a group data frame with
summarize or mutate or filter or whatnot
what Tipler will do is apply summarize
in a group by fashion or mutate and
group by fashion and so on where it
makes sense so here if I first group by
city and then summarize to calculate a
mean summon end variable D PI is going
to split the data in groups and
conceptually it's going to apply the
summary teaching the group separately
and put those summaries back together
into a final data frame this will be my
result this is how you can get group
group statistics or group wise summaries
from your data you'll notice that the
three variables like calculate with
summarized mean summon n or in the final
data set but to those d player has added
the city variable and that variable came
from the grouping criteria and it's
necessary for D player to add each
variable that's involved in the grouping
process so we know what the values of
mean summon n refer to so if we put this
process together this is what it looks
like we take our data we group it and we
get grouped by summaries in this case
I'm all taken to mean the the row of the
summary that applies a small it's just
the mean of the small group in this data
set here I'm grouping by size before I
scoping by city the rows don't have to
be near each other in a group everything
will just be grouped together based on
common values wherever those values
appear in the dataset once you have
group data you can remove the grouping
information with ungroup that can be
reassuring because you know sometimes I
want metadata
floating around but also if you were to
summarize a group dataset there will be
some ungrouping that occurs as well so
this dataset doesn't actually exist
there is a TV data set in the EDA WR
package but it's much more complicating
this one this is a simplified version
but you can imagine we could take this
data set that as different countries
different years different genders number
of cases the TB although there's more
than one case 99 in Afghanistan anyways
we could group it in this case we could
add more than one variable to the
grouping criteria and what group I will
do is I'll create a separate group for
each combination of those variables so
for example Afghanistan in 1999 will be
one group Afghanistan in 2000 will be a
separate group and so on and then we can
run summarize on that and what we'll get
is you know our summary but when you run
summarize on group to correct data
summarize we'll strip off one variable
from the grouping criteria so now that
it's made this summary is go strip off
the leftmost variable no the rightmost
variable in this case that's year and
what you'll end up with is a date is a
data set still grouped but it's only
grouped by country it's no longer
grouped by country and year now why do
that well this this output here on the
right was still grouped by country and
year each row would be a separate group
and at that point the grouping criteria
is not really that helpful go by
stripping off just the last grouping
criteria this will be grouped by country
and we can immediately run some rice on
it again and this time get summary
statistics based on the different
countries and now let's go peel off that
variable country and the data is no
longer grouped after we've summarized a
few times and this only applies in the
output that we get from this command
that's no longer grouped none of what
we're doing is gonna fake the actual TB
dataset that's just going to exist as it
always has in memory so this process of
grouping by many variables and then
summarizing fuelling off one level of
grouping criterias you go is a way to
change the unit of analysis that your
data looks at for example we can use the
process to make these four data sets
here they all come from the original TB
data but one of them is really
describing combinations of in this case
on the left country by year by sex and
then we change that to just country by
year and then we change that to just
country then we change that to the
entire dataset and different types of
information can become apparent at
different levels of grouping here and
summarization so I know it's been a lot
this is definitely gonna be a whirlwind
tour but we're near the end you can
extract variables and observations with
selecting filter you can rearrange your
data with a range you can make new
variables with mutate and you can make
new observations on new units analysis
by combining goodbye with summarize
thanks for checking out our data
wrangling video series this is just one
video in a larger set of resources on
data wrangling so here are links to all
of our other videos in the series and
again have a look at the video
description for shortcuts to other parts
of the series as well as other resources
we think might be helpful like cheat
sheets and further documentation we hope
you find all of these resources useful
and if you do as always we would
appreciate a thumbs up or a share both
go a long way to helping this content
reach people who could benefit from